It's an us versus them situation. To Felicia Blum, a freshman at Glenbrook South High School, it could not be more clear. There are fundamental differences between her school and its rival, Glenbrook North.
这是一种“我们”对“他们”的局面。对于格伦布鲁克南高中的新生费利西亚·布鲁姆来说，情况再清楚不过了。她的学校和竞争对手格伦布鲁克北高中之间存在根本性的差异。
The differences are basically the fact that the people at GBN are a little more snobby. Like, people have to fit a certain mold that people here don't have to do.
这些差异基本在于格伦布鲁克北高中的人更势利一些。就像人们必须符合某种特定的模板，而我们学校的人则不必。
And describe the mold. What is the mold that they're fitting into?
描述一下这个模板。他们需要符合什么样的模板？
Like, skinny, pretty. You don't necessarily have to be the nicest person. Good clothes, expensive clothes, expensive everything. Buffalo Jeans, Michael Stars, Kate Spade purses, backpacks, pencil bags.
比如，要瘦，要漂亮。你未必一定要是个好人。穿得好，穿昂贵的衣服，一切都要昂贵的。Buffalo牛仔裤、Michael Stars品牌、Kate Spade包包、背包、铅笔袋。
Go there, the kids at South tell me. You'll see. Over half the girls at Glenbrook North will have Kate Spade or Prada handbags. So I go. It's not far, just a few minutes across the Chicago suburbs. Now, traditionally, at this point in any story on public radio, or any after-school special for teenagers for that matter, what should happen next is that I should arrive at Glenbrook North and find out that, no, of course, kids in both schools are the same. Kids are kids. They're always the same.
南高中的孩子们告诉我，去那里看看吧，你就知道了。格伦布鲁克北高中超过一半的女孩都有Kate Spade或Prada手提包。于是我去了。那里并不远，穿过芝加哥郊区只需几分钟。按照传统，在公共广播的任何故事中，或者就此而言，任何给青少年的课后节目中，接下来应该发生的是：我抵达格伦布鲁克北高中后会发现，不，当然，两所学校的孩子们都是一样的。孩子就是孩子，他们总是没什么不同。
But it turns out that there are a lot of kids at Glenbrook North, GBN, who agree that they are snobbier.
但事实证明，格伦布鲁克北高中的很多孩子也同意他们确实更势利。
GBN is more, like-- you have to have this, and do your hair, and do your makeup. Everything.
格伦布鲁克北高中更像是——你必须拥有这些，得打理头发，还要化妆。事事如此。
Yeah. I think GBS is more comfortable with themselves as people than we are.
是的。我认为比起我们，格伦布鲁克南高中的孩子对自己作为一个人感觉更自在。
I know. Exactly.
我知道。没错。
We follow the crowd.
我们随波逐流。
Exactly. And if you're not in the in-crowd, then you're nothing. And everyone will think of you as just a big loser. And it's hard.
没错。如果你不属于那个核心圈子，那你什么都不是。每个人都会把你当成彻头彻尾的失败者。这很难受。
I was told that most of the girls at this school would be carrying either Kate Spade or Prada bags.
有人告诉我，这所学校的大多数女孩都会背Kate Spade或Prada包。
I have a Prada on right now, actually. Yeah. It's true.
说实话，我现在就背着一个Prada。是啊，是真的。
Is that true?
那是真的吗？
Kate Spade is true.
Kate Spade是真的。
That's true.
那是真的。
But laying it all out like this, here on the radio, exaggerates just how competitive the two schools are. Most kids didn't seem to care one way or the other about the subject. It was the kids who were the most invested in the idea of school spirit who feel the strongest that there's a difference between the schools. Like that first girl, Felicia Blum, for instance.
但像这样在电台里把一切摆出来，夸大了两所学校之间的竞争。大多数孩子似乎对此并不怎么在意。只有那些最投入学校精神的孩子，才最强烈地感受到两所学校之间的差异。比如第一个女孩，费利西亚·布鲁姆。
Yeah. I have a lot of spirit. I'm on poms, which is like dancing at the halftime shows, so I guess I'm a little high spirit. What can I say?
是的。我很有活力。我是拉拉队的，就是在中场秀跳舞的那种，所以我猜我的精神头比较高。我能说什么呢？
It's hard for there to be such a thing as "us" if you don't have a "them." And some people by disposition need a good "them." Other people tend to see "thems" of all sorts as more like "us," which is the subject of today's radio show. In this time of war, when we are all feeling a heightened sense of "us" and "them," we wanted to take up the problem of "them" with three stories of people misperceiving the "them-iness" of "them." From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in three vivid acts.
如果你没有一个“他们”，就很难存在“我们”这种概念。有些人从天性上就需要一个很好的“他们”。而另一些人倾向于将各种各样的“他们”视为更像“我们”，这正是今天广播节目的主题。在战争时期，当我们都感受到一种更加强烈的“我们”与“他们”的对立感时，我们想通过三个故事来探讨“他们”的问题，讲述人们如何误读了“他们”的“他者性”。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三个生动的篇章。
Act One, My Friend The Extremist. What happens if you're not sleeping with the enemy, but instead find that you are watching The Lion King with him.
第一章：我的极端分子朋友。如果你不是与敌人同床共枕，而是发现自己正在和他一起看《狮子王》，会发生什么？
Act Two, Don't They Know It's Christmas After All? In that act, David Sedaris tries to contemplate the barrenness of a world that has Santa, but no elves.
第二章：难道他们不知道这就是圣诞节吗？在这一章里，大卫·塞达里斯试图思考一个只有圣诞老人却没有精灵的世界的荒凉。
Act Three, Newfies. The story of an American sailor in World War II whose life was saved by foreigners and then threatened repeatedly by Americans. Us and them, reversed. Stay tuned.
第三章：纽芬兰人。一个在二战中被外国人救下，随后又屡次受到美国人威胁的美国水手的故事。我们与他们，身份发生了反转。敬请期待。
Act One, My Friend The Extremist. Several years ago, before many of us paid much attention to the name Osama bin Laden, reporter Jon Ronson started following around the religious leader who calls himself bin Laden's "man in London." At first, Ronson definitely thought that this leader was on the "them" side of "us" and "them." But once Ronson got to know him, he changed that opinion. In the year since September 11, he has been forced to change that opinion again, to the point where it is not exactly clear what to think. Here's Jon.
第一章：我的极端分子朋友。几年前，在我们大多数人还没有过多关注奥萨马·本·拉登这个名字时，记者乔恩·罗森开始追踪报道那位自称是“本·拉登伦敦代理人”的宗教领袖。起初，罗森肯定认为这位领袖属于“我们与他们”中“他们”的一方。但当罗森了解他之后，改变了看法。在911事件过去的一年里，他被迫再次改变了观点，以至于连他自己都不确定该怎么想了。下面是乔恩的报道。
I first met Omar Bakri Mohammed shortly after he declared holy war on Britain in 1995. There were maybe 5,000 of Omar Bakri's followers in Trafalgar Square when he announced that he wouldn't rest until he saw the black flag of Islam flying over Downing Street and the White House. There was much cheering. The stage had been rented out to him by the local city council, from which he outlined his post-jihad vision for the UK.
我第一次见到奥马尔·巴克里·穆罕默德是在他1995年对英国宣战后不久。当时在特拉法加广场，有大约5000名奥马尔·巴克里的追随者，他宣布在他看到伊斯兰黑旗在唐宁街和白宫上空飘扬之前，他绝不会休息。现场掌声雷动。舞台是他从当地市议会租来的，他在那里概述了他对英国的“圣战”后的愿景。
He who practiced homosexuality, adultery, fornication, or bestiality would be stoned to death or thrown from the highest mountain. Christmas decorations and shop window dummies would be outlawed. Pubs would be closed down. Pictures of ladies' legs on packets of pantyhose would be banned. We'd still be able to buy pantyhose, but they'd be advertised simply with the word "Pantyhose."
凡是从事同性恋、通奸、淫乱或兽交的人，都要被乱石砸死或从最高的山上扔下。圣诞装饰和商店橱窗里的模特将被取缔。酒吧将被关闭。连裤袜包装上女士腿部的图片将被禁止。我们仍然可以买到连裤袜，但包装上只会写上“连裤袜”这个词。
I very much wanted to meet Omar Bakri and spend time with him while he attempted to overthrow democracy and transform Britain into an Islamic nation. It turned out that he lived a couple of miles away from me in Edmonton, North London, in a small semi-detached house at the end of a cul-de-sac. I got his telephone number from the phone book. He called back straightaway. There were so many anti-Muslim lies, he said, generated by the Jewish-controlled media, so much misinformation in the newspapers and the movies. Perhaps this would be an opportunity for the record to be set straight. So yes, I was welcome to join him in his struggle against the infidels.
我非常想见奥马尔·巴克里，在他试图推翻民主并将英国转变为伊斯兰国家的过程中花点时间和他在一起。事实证明，他就住在我北伦敦埃德蒙顿几英里外，死胡同尽头的一栋小型半独立式住宅里。我从电话簿里找到了他的电话号码。他立刻回电了。他说，犹太人控制的媒体散布了太多反穆斯林的谎言，报纸和电影里有太多的错误信息。也许这是一个正本清源的机会。所以，是的，欢迎我加入他对抗异教徒的斗争。
And then he added, "I'm actually very nice, you know."
然后他又补充道：“其实我人很好，你知道吗。”
"Are you?" I asked.
“是吗？”我问。
"Oh, yes," said Omar Bakri. "I am delightful."
“哦，是的，”奥马尔·巴克里说，“我非常讨人喜欢。”
At 9:00 the next morning, I sat in Omar's living room while Omar played with his baby daughter. "What's your daughter's name?" I asked him.
第二天早上9点，我坐在奥马尔的客厅里，看他逗弄自己的小女儿。“你女儿叫什么名字？”我问他。
"It is a difficult name for you to understand," said Omar.
“这对你来说是个难以理解的名字，”奥马尔说。
"Does it have an English translation?" I asked.
“它有英语翻译吗？”我问。
"Oh, yes," said Omar. "It translates into English as The Black Flag of Islam."
“哦，有的，”奥马尔说，“翻译成英语就是‘伊斯兰的黑旗’。”
"Really?" I said. "Your daughter's name is The Black Flag of Islam?"
“真的吗？”我说，“你女儿的名字是‘伊斯兰的黑旗’？”
"Yes," said Omar.
“是的，”奥马尔说。
"Really?" I said. There was a small pause.
“真的吗？”我说。沉默了片刻。
"You see," said Omar, "why our cultures could never integrate?"
“你看，”奥马尔说，“这就是为什么我们的文化永远无法融合。”
The Lion King was playing on the video. We watched the scene where the warthog sung "Hakuna Matata," the song about how wonderful it is to have no worries and problem-free philosophies. Omar sang along, bouncing the baby on his knee. "We always watch The Lion King," he said. "It's the only way I can relax. You know, they call me The Lion. That's right. They call me The Lion. They call me the great warrior, the great fighter."
视频里正在放《狮子王》。我们看到疣猪唱着“哈库拉马塔塔”的那一幕，那是关于拥有无忧无虑的生活哲学是多么美妙的歌曲。奥马尔跟着唱，膝盖上颠着孩子。“我们总是看《狮子王》，”他说，“这是我放松的唯一方式。你知道，他们叫我‘狮子’。没错，他们叫我‘狮子’。他们称我为伟大的勇士，伟大的战士。”
Omar showed me his photo album. His teenage photographs made him look like a matinee idol. He came from a family of 28 brothers and sisters. His father had made a fortune selling sheep and pigs and cows. They had chauffeurs and servants and palaces in Syria and Turkey and Beirut. Omar escaped Saudi Arabia in 1985. He'd heard he was going to be arrested for preaching the jihad. He escaped to Britain. Now he's a big man with a big beard. "I was thin because I always worried," he said. "I was always on the run. Now I live in Britain. I never worry. What's going to happen to me here? Ha-ha. So I got fat. A leader must be big in stature. The bigger the body, the bigger the leader. Who wants a little, scrawny leader?"
奥马尔给我看了他的相册。他十几岁的照片让他看起来像个影星。他来自一个有28个兄弟姐妹的家庭。他的父亲靠卖羊、猪和牛发了财。他们在叙利亚、土耳其和贝鲁特有司机、仆人和宫殿。奥马尔于1985年逃离沙特阿拉伯。他听说自己要因为鼓吹圣战而被捕。他逃到了英国。现在他是一个留着大胡子的壮汉。“我以前很瘦，因为我总是担心，”他说，“我总是在逃亡。现在我住在英国。我从不担心。在这里我能有什么事？哈哈。所以我变胖了。领导者身材必须魁梧。身体越大，领导者就越大。谁会想要一个瘦弱的领导者？”
Omar's plan for the morning was to hand out leaflets entitled, "Homosexuality, Lesbianism, Adultery, Fornication, and Bestiality: The Deadly Diseases." He said he couldn't help notice my car in the driveway, so perhaps I would give him a lift.
奥马尔那天早上的计划是散发题为《同性恋、女同性恋、通奸、淫乱和兽交：致命的疾病》的传单。他说他注意到我的车在车道上，所以也许我可以载他一程。
"OK," I said. I dropped him off near the tube station. I went to park the car. 10 minutes later, I found him standing in the middle of the pavement with a stack of leaflets in his hand. "How's it going, Omar?" I asked.
“好吧，”我说。我把他放在地铁站附近。我去找车位。10分钟后，我发现他站在人行道中间，手里拿着一叠传单。“怎么样，奥马尔？”我问。
"Oh, very good," he smiled. "The message is getting across that there are some deadly diseases here and there." He turned to the passers-by. "Homosexuality," he yelled. "Beware the deadly disease. Beware the hour." Some time passed. "Homosexuality," yelled Omar. "Beware. There are homosexuals everywhere."
“哦，非常好，”他笑着说，“人们开始明白这里到处都有致命的疾病了。”他转向路人。“同性恋！”他大喊，“当心致命疾病。当心那个时刻。”过了一会儿，“同性恋！”奥马尔大喊，“当心！到处都是同性恋。”
I expected to see some hostility to Omar's leaflets from the passers-by. But the shoppers and tourists and office workers seemed to regard him with a kindly bemusement. Nonetheless, after 10 minutes, nobody had actually taken a leaflet. "Beware the hour. There are homosexuals everywhere. Beware the hour," continued Omar cheerfully. "Be careful from homosexuality. It is not good for your tummy."
我本以为路人会对奥马尔的传单产生敌意。但购物者、游客和上班族似乎只是带着一种善意的困惑看着他。尽管如此，10分钟过去了，实际上没人拿传单。“当心那个时刻。到处都是同性恋。当心那个时刻，”奥马尔愉快地继续喊道，“当心同性恋。它对你的肚子不好。”
Omar Bakri was unlike my image of a Muslim extremist. Then he told me he had a good idea. "Just watch this," he said. He turned the leaflets upside down. "Help the orphans," he yelled. "Help the orphans."
奥马尔·巴克里与我心目中的穆斯林极端分子形象截然不同。然后他告诉我他有一个好主意。“看着，”他说。他把传单倒了过来。“救救孤儿！”他大喊，“救救孤儿！”
"Omar," I exclaimed, scandalized. The passers-by started to accept the leaflets.
“奥马尔，”我惊讶地惊呼道。路人开始接受这些传单了。
"This is good," chuckled Omar. "This is good. You see? If I wasn't a Muslim, I'd be working for, how you say, Saatchi and Saatchi."
“这很好，”奥马尔轻笑着，“这很好。你明白吗？如果我不是穆斯林，我会去为，怎么说呢，萨奇广告公司工作。”
At lunchtime, Omar said he needed to buy some collection boxes for his regular fundraising endeavors for Hamas and Hezbollah. Hamas had orchestrated a bus bombing in Jerusalem three weeks earlier, which had killed 11 people. "There was a cash-and-carry just off the ring road near Tottenham," said Omar, "that sells very good collection boxes. Could you give me a lift?"
午餐时间，奥马尔说他需要为他经常进行的哈马斯和真主党筹款活动买一些募捐箱。三周前，哈马斯在耶路撒冷制造了一起公共汽车爆炸案，造成11人死亡。“托特纳姆附近环路旁有一家批发商，”奥马尔说，“卖的募捐箱非常好。你能载我一程吗？”
"OK," I said. So we drove to the cash-and-carry. Omar sat in the backseat, which made me feel a little like a taxi driver.
“好吧，”我说。于是我们开车去了批发商。奥马尔坐在后座，这让我感觉自己有点像出租车司机。
"Left," said Omar. "Left at the junction. No, left."
“左转，”奥马尔说，“在路口左转。不，左转。”
At some traffic lights, I asked Omar where his wife was when I was at his house. "She was upstairs," he said. "She wouldn't come down until after you left."
在等红绿灯时，我问奥马尔我去他家时他妻子在哪里。“她在楼上，”他说，“在你走之前她不会下来。”
"What would happen if I had tried to interview her?" I asked.
“如果我试图采访她会怎样？”我问。
"I would declare fatwa on you," said Omar.
“我会对你下达法特瓦（教令），”奥马尔说。
"Please don't say that," I said.
“请别那样说，”我说。
"Ha-ha," said Omar.
“哈哈，”奥马尔说。
"Even as a joke," I said.
“即使是开玩笑也不行，”我说。
We arrived at the cash-and-carry to discover that the only collection boxes they had in stock were large, plastic, novelty Coca-Cola bottles. Omar paused for a moment. He scrutinized the collection boxes. He furrowed his brow. Then he placed half a dozen of them in his shopping cart. "These are good collection boxes," he said. "Very big and lightweight."
我们到达批发商那里，发现他们库存中仅有的募捐箱是大型的塑料可口可乐 novelty 瓶。奥马尔停顿了一下。他仔细打量了一下这些募捐箱。他皱起眉头。然后他往购物车里放了半打。“这些募捐箱不错，”他说，“非常大，而且重量轻。”
"It seems strange to me," I said, "that you plan to collect for Hamas in novelty Coca-Cola bottles."
“这对我来说很奇怪，”我说，“你打算用可口可乐 novelty 瓶为哈马斯募捐。”
"Ah," said Omar Bakri. "I am not against the imperialist baggage. Just the corruption of Western civilization."
“啊，”奥马尔·巴克里说，“我不反对这些帝国主义的包装。我只反对西方文明的腐败。”
We packed our stuff into the trunk of my car, and I drove Omar to the Finsbury Park mosque, where he was to deliver a speech at a conference entitled, "Democracy or Dictatorship." Omar was speaking on behalf of dictatorship.
我们把东西装进后备箱，我开车送奥马尔去芬斯伯里公园清真寺，他要在那里发表题为“民主还是独裁”的会议演讲。奥马尔是代表独裁发言。
This was my first opportunity to meet some of Omar's followers. There were maybe 500 of them in the audience. Things did not start well.
这是我第一次见到奥马尔的一些追随者。听众席上有大约500人。事情开始得并不顺利。
"Are you a Jew?" asked a young man.
“你是犹太人吗？”一个年轻人问。
"Uh, no," I lied. He apologized. "Don't worry about it," I said.
“呃，不是，”我撒谎道。他道歉了。“别担心，”我说。
Omar Bakri was fast-talking on the podium, as if he couldn't contain the words that needed to be said. He filled the room. He quoted from a letter he'd just received from an old friend, Sheikh Omar Abdel-Rahman, The Blind Sheikh. The Blind Sheikh was in jail for life in Missouri for inspiring the first World Trade Center bombing in 1993. This law of "inspiration" had not been utilized since the American Civil War. Omar used to eat with The Blind Sheikh back in Saudi Arabia.
奥马尔·巴克里在讲台上语速极快，好像他无法抑制那些需要说出来的话。他充斥着整个房间。他引用了他刚收到的一位老朋友谢赫·奥马尔·阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼，即“盲人谢赫”的一封信。盲人谢赫因煽动1993年第一次世贸中心爆炸案而在密苏里州被判终身监禁。这种“煽动”罪名自美国内战以来就没再使用过。奥马尔以前在沙特阿拉伯时常和盲人谢赫一起吃饭。
After the speech, Omar said he needed to do some errands in town, and could I give him a lift? I agreed, although I feared I was beginning to cross the line between journalist and chauffeur. "I'm meeting someone in Soho," I said. "So can I drop you off there?"
演讲结束后，奥马尔说他需要在城里办些杂事，能不能载他一程？我同意了，尽管我担心自己开始跨越记者和司机的界限。“我在苏豪区有人要见，”我说，“所以我能把你放在那里吗？”
"No, no, no," he said anxiously. "It is forbidden for me to go into Soho. Please don't take me there." Soho would be razed to the ground, said Omar, once the holy war had been won. "It is important for people to understand these things," he said, "so they will be ready to adapt to the new ways."
“不，不，不，”他焦虑地说，“禁止我进入苏豪区。请不要带我去那里。”奥马尔说，一旦圣战胜利，苏豪区将被夷为平地，“人们理解这些事情很重要，”他说，“这样他们才能准备好适应新的生活方式。”
"Have you ever been to Soho?" I asked.
“你去过苏豪区吗？”我问。
"Oh, no," said Omar. "It is forbidden."
“哦，没有，”奥马尔说，“这是禁止的。”
"What do you imagine Soho to be like?" I asked.
“你想象中的苏豪区是什么样子的？”我问。
"There are naked women everywhere," he said. "Naked women standing on street corners."
“到处都是裸女，”他说，“街角站满了裸女。”
We got talking about the word "fundamentalist." Omar said it had been redefined by the infidels of the west as a pejorative term. "You use it as an insult," Omar said. "Turn left, please."
我们谈到了“原教旨主义者”这个词。奥马尔说它已经被西方的异教徒重新定义为一个贬义词。“你们把它当作一种侮辱，”奥马尔说，“请左转。”
"But surely you are a fundamentalist," I said, "in the sense that you live your life by the rules set down in the Quran."
“但你无疑是个原教旨主义者，”我说，“从你按照古兰经规定的规则生活这一意义上来说。”
"This is true," said Omar. "The Quran rules every aspect of my life. It tells me how I eat, how I sleep, how I fight, and even how I will die." Omar paused. "You know," he said, "the Quran even tells me which direction I must break wind in."
“这是真的，”奥马尔说，“古兰经支配着我生活的方方面面。它告诉我如何吃饭，如何睡觉，如何战斗，甚至我将如何死去。”奥马尔顿了顿，“你知道，”他说，“古兰经甚至告诉我在哪个方向放屁。”
There was a short silence. "And which direction do you break wind in?" I asked.
短暂的沉默。“那你是在哪个方向放屁呢？”我问。
"In the direction of the non-believer," Omar said. "The direction of the non-believer." Omar laughed heartily for some time, and he slapped me on the back.
“在非信徒的方向，”奥马尔说，“非信徒的方向。”奥马尔大声笑了很久，还拍了拍我的背。
"OK," said Omar as I pulled up near Piccadilly Circus. "Thank you very much. Goodbye, Jon."
“好吧，”我把车停在皮卡迪利广场附近时，奥马尔说，“非常感谢。再见，乔恩。”
As I drove away, I gave my horn a little beep, and I mouthed the words, "I'll call."
我开车离开时，按了一下喇叭，用口型说：“我会打电话的。”
As the months progressed, I found my life becoming increasingly determined by Omar's whims. "If you turn up late," he often said, "I will give you 60 lashes. Ha-ha." On many occasions, Omar would telephone and call me over urgently. I'd cancel nights out with my wife and drive over to discover that he'd forgotten all about me and had taken the train to Plymouth, or Nuneaton, or to his secret jihad training camp near Crawley. I sometimes felt I was getting a unique insight into what it would be like living under Islamic rule with Omar as ayatollah.
随着几个月的过去，我发现我的生活越来越受奥马尔心血来潮的摆布。“如果你迟到了，”他常说，“我会给你60鞭子。哈哈。”在许多情况下，奥马尔会打电话紧急叫我过去。我会取消与妻子的夜晚计划，驱车赶去，却发现他早忘了这回事，自己坐火车去普利茅斯、纽尼顿或者他克劳利附近的秘密圣战训练营了。有时我觉得我正在获得一种独特的见解，了解在奥马尔担任阿亚图拉的情况下生活在伊斯兰统治下是什么感觉。
Time passed, and then it was January, the first day of Ramadan. For months now, I'd been asking Omar to take me to his secret jihad training camp in Crawley, an anonymous commuter town near Gatwick Airport, which seemed a rather incongruous location for a jihad training camp. Finally, he agreed.
时间流逝，转眼到了1月，斋月的第一天。几个月来，我一直要求奥马尔带我去他位于克劳利的秘密圣战训练营，那是一个盖特威克机场附近的匿名通勤小镇，对于圣战训练营来说，这似乎是个相当不协调的地点。最终，他同意了。
We were picked up at Crawley station by some young local followers. These were people I'd never seen before. Omar said that in every town and city in the country, and many towns abroad, there were clustered his supporters. "When you put those people together," said Omar, "you have an army." "Oh, yes," he continued. "There's a day when military struggle will take place in the UK. Jihad. It's called 'conquering.' One day, without question, the UK is going to be governed by Islam. The Muslims in Britain must not be naive. They must be ready to defend themselves militarily. The struggle, as I always say, is a struggle between two civilizations. The civilization of man against the civilization of God."
我们在克劳利站被一些当地年轻的追随者接走了。这些人我以前从未见过。奥马尔说，在这个国家的每个城镇和城市，以及国外的许多城镇，都聚集着他的支持者。“当你把这些人聚在一起时，”奥马尔说，“你就拥有了一支军队。”“哦，是的，”他继续说，“总有一天会在英国发生军事斗争。圣战。它被称为‘征服’。总有一天，毫无疑问，英国将由伊斯兰治理。英国的穆斯林绝不能天真。他们必须做好军事自卫的准备。正如我常说，这场斗争是两种文明之间的斗争。人的文明对抗上帝的文明。”
We were driven to the jihad training camp, a well-stocked gym in a scout hut in a forestry center. Snow lay on the ground. Inside, a young man wearing boxing gloves was beating a punch bag, and Omar immediately instructed him to focus his assault. "On the head," he said. "That's it. The head. Easy, easy. OK, stop now. Rest. Rest. You kill him. You kill him." The group laughed, and I laughed too.
我们被带到了圣战训练营，一个位于林业中心童子军小屋里的设备齐全的健身房。地上覆盖着雪。里面，一个戴着拳击手套的年轻人正在打沙袋，奥马尔立即指示他集中火力。“对着头，”他说，“就是这样。头。轻松，轻松。好了，停下。休息。休息。你杀了他。你杀了他。”小组笑了起来，我也跟着笑了。
I was standing in one corner with my back against the wall. I found the situation slightly uncomfortable. And then, apropos of nothing, Omar made an announcement to the group. "Look at me," he said. "Here I am with an infidel. Jon--" Omar paused for effect "--is a Jew." There was an audible gasp followed by a long silence. Of all the locations in which Omar could have chosen to disclose this sensational revelation, a packed jihad training camp in the middle of a forest was not the place I'd have hoped for. I found myself searching for the fastest path to the door.
我背靠墙站在一个角落里。我发现这种情况让我有点不舒服。然后，没来由地，奥马尔向小组做了一个声明。“看着我，”他说，“我这里有一个异教徒。乔恩——”奥马尔故意停顿以引起注意，“是犹太人。”人群中传出惊呼，随后是一片长时间的沉默。在奥马尔可以选择透露这个惊人事实的所有地点中，森林中间一个拥挤的圣战训练营绝不是我所希望的。我发现自己正在寻找最快的逃生路线。
"Are you really a Jew?" said someone eventually.
“你真的是犹太人吗？”有人最终问道。
"Well," I said lightly. "Surely it's better to be a Jew than an atheist." There was a silence.
“嗯，”我轻描淡写地说，“难道做犹太人总比做无神论者好吗？”一片沉默。
"No, it isn't," said a voice from the crowd.
“不，并不是，”人群中传来一个声音。
"When did you know I was Jewish?" I asked Omar.
“你什么时候知道我是犹太人的？”我问奥马尔。
"From the beginning," he said. "I could see it in your eyes. Why didn't you tell me?"
“从一开始，”他说，“我从你的眼睛里就能看出来。你为什么不告诉我？”
"Well," I said. "You know."
“嗯，”我说，“你知道的。”
"Are you ashamed to be a Jew?" said Omar. "You deny it?"
“你羞于成为犹太人吗？”奥马尔说，“你否认它？”
"No," I said.
“不，”我说。
"I am not offended that you are a Jew," said Omar. "We are all Semites. If you were Israeli, if you were Zionist, that is a different matter, but what offends me is that you hide it. You assimilate. That you have no pride."
“我并不因为你是犹太人而感到被冒犯，”奥马尔说，“我们都是闪米特人。如果你是以色列人，如果你是犹太复国主义者，那是另一回事，但让我感到冒犯的是你隐藏了它。你同化了。你没有自尊。”
"I am proud," I said, unconvincingly. But of course, Omar was right. I should have told him.
“我很自豪，”我说，语气不太坚定。但当然，奥马尔是对的。我应该告诉他的。
"Assimilation," tutted Omar. "Integration. These are the worst things of all. Be a Jew."
“同化，”奥马尔咂嘴说，“融合。这些是最糟糕的事情。做个犹太人吧。”
In the years that followed my time with Omar, he sporadically made the papers, calling for this fatwa or that fatwa, reaffirming the fatwa on Salman Rushdie after Iran had lifted it. But he also began to seem increasingly anachronistic, a spent force. All that would change during the week of September the 11th, 2001. The first sign that Omar had decided to initiate his own endgame came in the form of a press release he posted on his website on September the 12th. It read, "The final hour will not come until the Muslims conquer the White House. As America declares war on 1.5 billion Muslims worldwide, what is your duty?"
在我与奥马尔相处之后的几年里，他偶尔会上报纸，呼吁这个法特瓦或那个法特瓦，在伊朗解除对萨尔曼·鲁西迪的追杀令后，他又重申了该令。但他似乎也变得越来越不合时宜，成为强弩之末。所有这一切在2001年9月11日那一周发生了改变。奥马尔决定开启他自己结局的第一个迹象，是他9月12日在网站上发布的一份新闻稿。上面写着：“在穆斯林征服白宫之前，最后时刻不会到来。当美国向全球15亿穆斯林宣战时，你的义务是什么？”
Omar then gave a series of newspaper interviews in which he spoke of his delight at the attacks. "Oh, wow," he told the Daily Mail . "The United States has come under attack. It's exciting." A number of his British followers joined the Taliban. At least three were, in Omar's words, "martyred" because of it. The conservative leader, during an emergency session of Parliament, called for a change in the law, so Omar could be deported. Scotland Yard arrested Omar, and then they released him. He'd committed no crime.
奥马尔随后接受了一系列报纸采访，谈到了他对袭击的欣喜。“哦，哇，”他告诉《每日邮报》，“美国受到了攻击。这太令人兴奋了。”他的一些英国追随者加入了塔利班。用奥马尔的话说，至少有三个人因此“殉道”。保守党领袖在议会紧急会议上呼吁修改法律，以便将奥马尔驱逐出境。苏格兰场逮捕了奥马尔，然后又释放了他。他没有犯罪。
I telephoned Omar on the evening of his arrest. I expected to find him in defiant mood, but he seemed a little scared. "This is so terrible," he said. "The police say they may deport me. Why are people linking me with bin Laden? I do not know the man. I've never met him. Why do people say I'm bin Laden's man in Great Britain?"
我在他被捕的那天晚上给奥马尔打了电话。我本以为他会表现出挑衅的态度，但他似乎有点害怕。“这太可怕了，”他说，“警察说他们可能会把我驱逐出境。为什么人们把我与本·拉登联系在一起？我不认识那个人。我从未见过他。为什么人们说我是本·拉登在英国的代理人？”
"Because you've been calling yourself bin Laden's man in Great Britain for years," I said.
“因为你多年来一直自称是本·拉登在英国的代理人，”我说。
"Oh, Jon," said Omar. "I need you more than ever now. You know I'm harmless, don't you? You always said I was laughable, didn't you? Oh, Jon, why don't people believe you when you tell them I'm just a harmless clown?"
“哦，乔恩，”奥马尔说，“我现在比以往任何时候都更需要你。你知道我是无害的，不是吗？你一直说我很可笑，不是吗？哦，乔恩，为什么当你告诉人们我只是个无害的小丑时，他们不相信你呢？”
Of course, someone who's a clown isn't always harmless. I thought about Omar when I watched the World Trade Center fall to the ground. Had he been a monster all this time masquerading as a friendly buffoon to fool guileless liberals like me? I wondered if he'd duped me, or worse, if I'd duped myself. Someone once told me that I suffer from the great liberal misconception that everyone is basically good underneath. I'd argue instead that most people are a mix of good and bad, and that to see ourselves in them is better than seeing them as inhuman, as something that is impossible to recognize. But I have to admit, there are moments when I think I went too far in befriending Omar.
当然，小丑并不总是无害的。当我看着世贸中心倒塌时，我想到了奥马尔。他一直是个伪装成友好小丑来愚弄像我这样天真的自由派的怪物吗？我怀疑他是否欺骗了我，更糟糕的是，是否我自己欺骗了自己。有人曾告诉我，我患有巨大的自由主义误解，认为每个人内心本质上都是好的。我反而会说，大多数人是好与坏的混合体，在我们身上看到他们，比把他们视为非人——即那些无法识别的东西——要好得多。但我不得不承认，有时我会觉得我在与奥马尔交往时走得太远了。
The last time I saw him in person was 1996. It had been a year since he bought his novelty Coca-Cola Hamas collection boxes from the cash-and-carry. They were full now, of loose change and GBP 50 notes. There was a check for GBP 5,000 in one. Omar and his deputy, Anjem, were taking the collection boxes to the bank. The money would be converted into foreign currency and shipped off to the Middle East, where it would be used in the fight against Israel. Omar had some business to finish. Anjem packed the bottles in the back of his car. Then he remembered that he'd left his coat inside. He said, "Could you guard the money for a moment? I won't be long."
我最后一次亲自见到他是1996年。距离他从批发商那里购买可口可乐novelty哈马斯募捐箱已经一年了。现在箱子里装满了零钱和50英镑的钞票。其中一张里还有一张5000英镑的支票。奥马尔和他的副手安杰姆正带着募捐箱去银行。这些钱将被兑换成外币并运往中东，用于对抗以色列的斗争。奥马尔还有些事情要处理。安杰姆把瓶子塞进车后座。然后他想起自己的外套落在了里面。他说：“你能帮我守一会儿钱吗？我很快就回来。”
"OK," I said. Anjem disappeared, and I was left standing guard over thousands of pounds, money that would go to Hamas to kill the Jews in Israel. For a while I stood there. And what was I doing, guarding money that would be used to kill the Jews? And then I understood that I had to take the money. I had to reach into the car, grab the Coca-Cola bottles, and make a run for it. This was my responsibility, my duty. I had an obligation to do this. I had the strength to carry two bottles. How many lives might that save?
“好吧，”我说。安杰姆消失了，我留下来守着几千英镑，这些钱将送给哈马斯去杀害以色列的犹太人。有一阵子我站在那里。我到底在做什么，守着将用于杀害犹太人的钱？然后我意识到我必须拿走这些钱。我必须伸手进车里，抓起可口可乐瓶，然后跑掉。这是我的责任，我的义务。我有义务这样做。我有力气拿两个瓶子。那能挽救多少人的生命？
Omar and Anjem were inside. The car was unlocked. But I didn't do it, of course. I just stood there. And then Anjem and Omar returned, thanked me for my help, and took the money to the bank.
奥马尔和安杰姆在里面。车没锁，但我当然没有那么做。我只是站在那里。然后安杰姆和奥马尔回来了，感谢我的帮助，把钱带到了银行。
Jon Ronson. In the year since he followed Omar Bakri, Bakri left London and then was banned from returning into England. He now lives in Lebanon.
乔恩·罗森。在追踪奥马尔·巴克里之后的一年里，巴克里离开了伦敦，随后被禁止返回英国。他现在居住在黎巴嫩。
Coming up, David Sedaris puts the "damn" back in Amsterdam. You can say that on the radio, right? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯要把“该死的”一词重新带回阿姆斯特丹。你在广播里可以这么说，对吧？稍后来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Them, stories of how we sometimes expect "them" to be more like "us," or less like us, other times, and wrongly. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Don't They Know It's Christmas After All?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周节目都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“他们”，讲述我们有时如何错误地期望“他们”更像“我们”，或者在其他时候不像我们。我们已经进入节目的第二章。第二章：难道他们不知道这就是圣诞节吗？
When we travel overseas, most of us want to embrace the "them-iness" of other countries and cultures. But that can be hard when we confine ourselves to museums, shopping, restaurants. David Sedaris has devised a few things to talk about while overseas to get a glimpse of the ways in which people are different from us.
当我们去海外旅游时，我们大多数人都想拥抱其他国家和文化的“他者性”。但当我们把自己局限在博物馆、购物、餐厅时，这可能会很难。大卫·塞达里斯在海外时设计了一些话题来谈论，以便一窥人们与我们不同的方式。
I've never been much for guidebooks, so when traveling abroad, my first question usually relates to barnyard animals. "What do your roosters say?" is a good icebreaker, as every country has its own unique interpretation.
我从来都不喜欢旅游指南，所以当出国旅游时，我的第一个问题通常与农场动物有关。“你们的公鸡怎么叫？”是一个很好的破冰话题，因为每个国家都有自己独特的诠释。
Grecian roosters crow "kiri-a-kee," and in France, they scream "coco-rico," which sounds like an order for one of those horrible pre-mixed cocktails with the pirate on the label. When told that an American rooster says "cock-a-doodle-doo," my hosts look at me with disbelief and pity.
希腊的公鸡叫“kiri-a-kee”，在法国，它们叫“coco-rico”，听起来就像在点某种带有海盗标签的可怕预调鸡尾酒。当被告知美国的公鸡叫“cock-a-doodle-doo”时，我的主人会带着怀疑和怜悯看着我。
"When do you open your Christmas presents?" is another good question, because I think it explains a lot about national character. In France and Germany, gifts are exchanged on Christmas Eve, while in Holland, the children open their presents on December 6, which is nationally celebrated as Saint Nicholas Day. It sounded sort of quaint until I spoke to a man named Oscar, who filled me in on a few of the details as we walked from my hotel to the Amsterdam train station.
“你们什么时候拆圣诞礼物？”是另一个好问题，因为我认为这在很大程度上解释了国民性格。在法国和德国，礼物在平安夜交换，而在荷兰，孩子们在12月6日拆礼物，那一天全国庆祝圣尼古拉斯日。这听起来有点古雅，直到我与一个名叫奥斯卡的男人交谈，他在我们从酒店走到阿姆斯特丹火车站时，向我透露了一些细节。
Unlike the jolly, obese American Santa, Saint Nicholas is painfully thin and dresses not unlike the Pope, topping his robes with a tall hat resembling an embroidered tea cozy. The outfit, I was told, is a carryover from his former career, when he served as the bishop of Turkey.
与快乐、肥胖的美国圣诞老人不同，圣尼古拉斯瘦得令人痛苦，穿着像教皇一样的长袍，头上戴着一顶类似刺绣茶套的高帽子。据我所知，这身装束是他以前担任土耳其主教时的职业习惯。
"I'm sorry," I said, "but could you repeat that?" One doesn't want to be too much of a cultural chauvinist, but this seemed completely wrong to me. For starters, Santa didn't "used to do" anything. He's not retired, and, more importantly, he has nothing to do with Turkey. It's too dangerous there, and the people wouldn't appreciate him. When asked how he got from Turkey to the North Pole, Oscar told me with complete conviction that Saint Nicholas currently resides in Spain, which again is simply not true.
“对不起，”我说，“你能再说一遍吗？”人不想成为太多的文化沙文主义者，但这对我来说似乎完全错了。首先，圣诞老人“以前并不做什么”。他没有退休，更重要的是，他与土耳其毫无关系。那里太危险了，人们也不会欣赏他。当被问及他怎么从土耳其到北极时，奥斯卡满怀信心地告诉我，圣尼古拉斯目前住在西班牙，这同样是不真实的。
While our Santa flies in on a sled, the Dutch version arrives by boat and then transfers to a white horse. The event is televised, and great crowds gather at the waterfront to greet him. I'm not sure if there's a set date, but he generally docks in late November and spends a few weeks hanging out and asking people what they want. "Is it just him alone?" I asked. "Or does he come with some backup?" Oscar's English was close to perfect, but he seemed thrown by a term normally reserved for police reinforcement. "Helpers," I said. "Does he have any elves?" Maybe I'm just overly sensitive, but I couldn't help but feel personally insulted when Oscar denounced the very idea as, quote, "grotesque and unrealistic."
当我们的圣诞老人坐雪橇飞来时，荷兰版本的是乘船抵达，然后换乘一匹白马。这项活动是电视转播的，大量人群聚集在海滨迎接他。我不确定是否有固定的日期，但他通常在11月下旬靠岸，花几周时间闲逛，询问人们想要什么。“是他一个人吗？”我问，“还是带着随从？”奥斯卡的英语几乎完美，但他似乎被一个通常保留给警察增援的词搞糊涂了。“帮手，”我说，“他有精灵吗？”也许我太敏感了，但当奥斯卡把这个想法谴责为“荒谬且不现实”时，我感到个人受到了侮辱。
"Elves," he said. "They're just so silly."
“精灵，”他说，“它们太蠢了。”
The words "silly" and "unrealistic" were redefined when I learned that Saint Nicholas travels with what was consistently described as six to eight black men. I asked several Dutch people to narrow it down, but none of them could give me an exact number. It was always six to eight, which seemed strange considering they've had hundreds of years to get a decent headcount. The six to eight black men were characterized as personal slaves until the mid-1950s, when the political climate changed, and it was decided that instead of being slaves, they were just good friends. I think history has proven that something usually comes between slavery and friendship, a period of time marked not by cookies and quiet hours beside the fire, but by bloodshed and mutual hostility.
当我了解到圣尼古拉斯旅行时带着六到八个黑人时，我对“蠢”和“不现实”这两个词有了新的定义。我问了几个荷兰人想让他们给出具体数字，但没人能给我一个确切的数字。总是六到八个，这很奇怪，考虑到他们已经有几百年的时间来统计人数了。这六到八个黑人直到20世纪50年代中期都被描述为私人奴隶，当时政治气候发生了变化，决定了他们不再是奴隶，而是好朋友。我认为历史证明，奴隶制和友谊之间通常会有一些东西，那是一段不仅没有饼干和炉火旁的宁静时光，反而以流血和相互敌意为特征的时期。
They have such violence in Holland, but rather than duking it out amongst one another, Santa and the former slaves decided to take it out on the public. In the early years, if a child was naughty, Saint Nicholas and the six to eight black men would beat him with what Oscar described as "the small branch of a tree." Then, if the youngster was really bad, they'd put him in a sack and take him back to Spain.
荷兰有这种暴力，但与其相互争斗，圣诞老人和前奴隶们决定在公众身上发泄。在早期，如果孩子淘气，圣尼古拉斯和那六到八个黑人会用奥斯卡描述为“树的小树枝”来打他。然后，如果孩子真的很坏，他们会把他装进麻袋带回西班牙。
"Wait a minute. Saint Nicholas would kick you?"
“等一下。圣尼古拉斯会踢你？”
"Well, not any more," Oscar said. "Now he just pretends to kick you."
“嗯，现在不会了，”奥斯卡说，“现在他只是假装踢你。”
He considered this to be progressive, but in a way I think it's almost more perverse than the original punishment. "I'm going to hurt you, but not really."
他认为这是一种进步，但在某种程度上，我认为这比最初的惩罚更反常。“我要伤害你，但不是真的。”
While eight flying reindeer are a hard pill to swallow, our Christmas story remains relatively dull. Santa lives with his wife in a remote polar village and spends one night a year traveling around the world. If you're bad, he leaves you coal. If you're good and live in America, he'll give you just about anything you want. We tell our children to be good and send them off to bed, where they lie awake anticipating their great bounty.
虽然八只飞行的驯鹿很难让人接受，但我们的圣诞故事相对沉闷。圣诞老人和妻子住在偏远的极地村庄，每年花一个晚上环游世界。如果你表现不好，他会给你煤炭。如果你表现好，住在美国家里，他几乎会给你任何你想要的。我们告诉孩子们要乖，把他们送上床，他们躺着清醒地期待着丰厚的礼物。
A Dutch parent has a decidedly tastier story to relate, telling his children, "Listen, you might want to pack a few of your things together before going to bed. The former bishop of Turkey will be coming tonight along with six to eight black men. They might put some candy in your shoes. They might stuff you into a sack and take you to Spain. Or they might just pretend to kick you. We don't know for sure, but we want you to be prepared."
荷兰父母有一个非常有趣的故事要讲，他们会告诉孩子：“听着，上床前你可能想收拾一下你的东西。土耳其的前主教今晚要来，带着六到八个黑人。他们可能会在你的鞋里放些糖果。他们可能会把你塞进麻袋带去西班牙。或者他们可能只是假装踢你。我们不确定，但我们希望你做好准备。”
This is the reward for living in Holland. As a child, you get to hear this story. And as an adult, you get to turn around and repeat it. As an added bonus, the government has thrown in legalized drugs and prostitution. So what's not to love about being Dutch?
这就是住在荷兰的奖励。小时候，你就能听到这个故事。成年后，你又回过头来重复它。作为额外福利，政府还引入了合法化的毒品和卖淫。那么，做荷兰人有什么不好的呢？
David Sedaris strives for international understanding in several books. This one appears in Dress Your Children in Corduroy and Denim.
大卫·塞达里斯在几本书中致力于国际理解。这一篇出现在《给你孩子穿上灯芯绒和牛仔》中。
Which brings us to Act Three, Newfies. We end our program with this story in which "us" and "them" are reversed. All the people who should be on the side of the man in this story are actually against him, and all the foreigners, who might be bad to him, actually treat him like one of their own. Chris Brookes put the story together.
这就把我们带到了第三章：纽芬兰人。我们以这个“我们”和“他们”身份反转的故事结束我们的节目。在这个故事中，所有本应站在那个男人这一边的人实际上都在反对他，而所有可能对他不利的外国人，实际上却像对待自己人一样对待他。克里斯·布鲁克斯整理了这个故事。
Go right in where he came out of. That's the bridge [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
直接走进他出来的地方。那就是桥。[语音不清]
I'm driving through the small town of Saint Lawrence, Newfoundland, Canada. It's about 300 miles from where I live myself, and the population is 1,697, according to that road sign. It's on the edge of a boot of rock that sticks right out into the North Atlantic shipping lanes. When you see this place on the map, it looks like a big foot waiting to trip unwary sailors. The person giving me directions here is Ena Edwards. She's kind of the unofficial Saint Lawrence historian.
我正开车穿过加拿大纽芬兰的圣劳伦斯小镇。这里离我住的地方大约300英里，根据路牌显示，人口为1697人。它位于一块直接伸入北大西洋航道的岩石靴的边缘。当你在地图上看到这个地方时，它看起来就像一只等着绊倒粗心水手的大脚。在这里为我指路的是埃娜·爱德华兹。她算是非官方的圣劳伦斯历史学家。
And you turn left up here by the stop sign. Do you see the high school's down there?
然后在停车标志这里左转。你看到那边的中学了吗？
Newfoundland is a place that some mainland Canadians like to make jokes about. They imagine that we're an island of some kind of naive fisherfolk. And actually, naive isn't the right word. Stupid is what they think we are. And the jokes they tell about us are called Newfie jokes. How many of us does it take to screw in a light bulb, that kind of thing. And when I first heard this story, it was in that kind of a context, a funny story about isolated Newfoundlanders just too naive to know what would have been obvious to most other people in North America. But lately, I've found out the rest of the story, and it wasn't a joke at all.
纽芬兰是一个有些加拿大内陆人喜欢开玩笑的地方。他们想象我们是一个由某种天真的渔民组成的岛屿。事实上，天真这个词并不准确。愚蠢才是他们认为我们的样子。他们讲的关于我们的笑话被称为“纽芬兰笑话”。比如我们要几个人才能换个灯泡之类的。当我第一次听到这个故事时，它就是在那种背景下，一个关于孤立的纽芬兰人太过天真，以至于不知道对北美大多数其他人来说是显而易见的事情的滑稽故事。但最近，我了解了故事的全部内容，这根本不是一个笑话。
We're getting close to it though.
不过我们快到了。
Where Ena's taking me here is to the new school playground. But the playground is really the end of this story. The beginning of it is 3,000 miles south of here, all the way down in DeKalb County, Georgia.
埃娜带我来的地方是新学校的操场。但操场实际上是这个故事的终点。它的起点在南边3000英里外，一直到佐治亚州的迪卡尔布县。
If you'll step in here, I'll show you, that's Saint Lawrence.
如果你进来，我给你看，那就是圣劳伦斯。
That photograph.
那张照片。
Yeah, that's Saint Lawrence. And here's my great-grandmother and grandfather, who were born slaves.
是的，那是圣劳伦斯。这是我出生为奴的曾祖母和祖父。
Well, I'm Lanier Phillips. I was born March 14, 1923, and I live in DeKalb County. And DeKalb County didn't furnish schools for black people until 1939. They didn't want the blacks to have any kind of education. Then they had the Klan, the Ku Klux Klan. And they instilled fear in the black people. At least they tried. And I know they had fear into me from five or six years old.
我是拉尼尔·菲利普斯。我出生于1923年3月14日，住在迪卡尔布县。在1939年之前，迪卡尔布县不为黑人提供学校。他们不想让黑人接受任何教育。然后他们有了三K党，库克拉克斯科兰。他们向黑人灌输恐惧。至少他们尝试了。我知道他们从我五六岁起就让我感到恐惧。
And I would go up the railroad track and see them come down Main Street, marching every Saturday night. They would march. And then at other times, they would be on this truck, and they would fire a shot in the air or something like that. And I knew which way they were going. When they crossed the railroad track, if they kept going straight, I knew they was going to a place called Smokey Row, predominantly black. Well, it was all black. But if they made a right turn, I knew they was coming down to what we call Bruce's Alley, where I live. And I'd take off like a jackrabbit and tell people, they're coming. And everybody would put the lamps out. They didn't have electricity.
我会顺着铁轨走，看他们每个星期六晚上在大街上游行。他们会游行。有时，他们会在卡车上，对着天空开枪什么的。我知道他们要去哪里。当他们穿过铁轨时，如果他们继续直走，我知道他们要去一个叫斯莫基街的地方，那里主要是黑人。嗯，全是黑人。但如果他们右转，我知道他们要来我们称之为布鲁斯巷的地方，也就是我住的地方。我会像野兔一样跑掉，告诉大家，他们来了。每个人都会熄灯。那时候他们没有电。
But they did some terrible things.
但他们确实做了一些可怕的事情。
Black people had a chance to build the school themselves. They called  it Yellow Ribbon. Three counties, Rockdale, Gwinnett County, and DeKalb County, got together and built this school, but the Ku Klux Klan burned the school down. Yes, sir. They burned it. I remember that clear. I can close my eyes and see the flames going, standing, and watching the school burn, and listening to the grown-ups say, they'll never let us learn or let our children learn to read.
黑人有机会自己建学校。他们称之为“黄丝带”。三个县，罗克代尔、格温内特县和迪卡尔布县，聚在一起建了这所学校，但三K党烧毁了学校。是的，先生。他们烧了它。我记得很清楚。我可以闭上眼睛，看到火焰升起，站在那里看着学校燃烧，听着大人们说，他们永远不会让我们学习，也不会让我们孩子学习读书。
I saw no future. I had no dreams because the only thing I could say, well, maybe I'll be a sharecropper or something once I grew up. So I said, I think I'll join the navy. So in '41, I joined the navy. Well, they had blacks in one place and whites in another. And blacks better not interfere, go down to the whites' showers or bathroom or anything like that. And the blacks on board ship, they could only be mess attendants, serving and what they called taking care of your officer. You were assigned a certain amount of officers. You kept his shoes shined, his clothing ready, and his room cleaned. And you'd be out for 30 days or more. You had to wash those officers' underwear.
我看不到未来。我没有梦想，因为我唯一能说的就是，也许我长大后会成为一名佃农什么的。所以我说，我想我要加入海军。所以在41年，我加入了海军。好吧，他们把黑人和白人分开安置。黑人最好不要干涉，去白人的淋浴间或浴室什么的。船上的黑人只能做勤务兵，服务和他们所谓的照顾军官。你被指派一定数量的军官。你负责擦亮他的鞋子，准备好他的衣服，清理他的房间。你要出海30天或更长时间。你必须洗那些军官的内衣。
Well, in the convoys, we had a lot of merchant ships. And we would escort them up to Iceland. And then the British would take over the convoy and take them on into England. And the home port was Boston, and as soon as we left Boston, it was storming. And we'd join up off of Halifax. I thought we were heading for Iceland. I said, well, I won't get off the ship until we get back to the States.
在护航队中，我们有很多商船。我们会护送它们到冰岛。然后英国人接管护航队并带它们进入英国。母港是波士顿，我们一离开波士顿，就遇到风暴。我们在哈利法克斯附近汇合。我以为我们要去冰岛。我说，好吧，在我们回到美国之前，我不会下船。
Because the previous trip had been to Iceland. And no blacks could go ashore there because they had some agreement with America that they would never let a black man put foot in Iceland. And they had the same agreement in Morocco. At Port Lyautey, they had a base there. And they said no Jew could ever stand there. And that was the agreement. And that's the way it was. That's the way it was.
因为上一次旅行是去冰岛。没有任何黑人可以上岸，因为他们与美国有一些协议，他们永远不会让黑人踏入冰岛。他们在摩洛哥也有同样的协议。在利奥泰港，他们有一个基地。他们说没有犹太人可以在那里站立。这就是协议。事情就是这样。
My maiden name was Farrell, which I kept after I married. So I'm Ena Farrell Edwards. And at the time of the disaster in 1942, February the 18th, in Saint Lawrence, it was Ash Wednesday. And it was a ferocious storm, a real blizzard.
我的娘家姓是法雷尔，婚后我也保留着这个姓。所以我叫埃娜·法雷尔·爱德华兹。在1942年2月18日圣劳伦斯发生灾难时，那天是圣灰星期三。那是一场猛烈的风暴，一场真正的暴风雪。
I heard the XO, the executive officer, tell the captain, this is going to be a rough one.
我听到执行官告诉船长，这将是一场恶战。
I'm Gus Etchegary. I was about 16 and a half in 1942, just finished high school in Saint Lawrence. Oh, it was a huge-- it was a hell of a storm. There was no doubt about it at all. I don't know what the estimate of the winds would be, but it had the full strife of the Atlantic.
我是格斯·埃切加里。1942年时我大约16岁半，刚在圣劳伦斯高中毕业。哦，这是一场巨大的——那绝对是一场地狱般的风暴。毫无疑问。我不知道风速估计是多少，但它遭受了大西洋的全力冲击。
And I guess many people said, maybe it was even said in our house, what a dreadful night. We pity the poor sailors on the sea tonight.
我想很多人都说，也许在我们家也说过，多么可怕的夜晚。今晚我们为海上的可怜水手感到难过。
Truxtun had no radar, so what they did was rely on dead reckoning.
特鲁克斯顿号没有雷达，所以他们所做的是依靠航位推测。
Before they knew it, they were right into the cliff. Bang.
在他们知道之前，他们已经直接撞向了悬崖。砰。
I thought we had been torpedoed. I didn't know what-- I was in my bed when it hit. Down I came. I had all my clothes on. I had my life jacket. And I grabbed a pair of shoes-- I didn't know if it was mine or what-- and went topside. Well, it was dark. And it was storming. I mean it was picking the Truxtun up and, it looked like, just slam it against the rock. And you could hear the steel grinding.
我以为我们被鱼雷击中了。我不知道——撞击时我正在床上。我下来了。我穿好了所有的衣服。我穿上了救生衣。我抓了一双鞋——我不知道是不是我的，管他呢——然后去了甲板。好吧，天很黑。而且风暴肆虐。我的意思是，海浪把特鲁克斯顿号抬起来，看起来就像把它重重地砸在岩石上。你可以听到钢铁的摩擦声。
Then when day began to break, all you could see was the cliffs and the rocks. And it just picked the ship up and down it would go. And began to wash the fellows overboard. I almost got washed over two or three times, but I'd grab that lifeline and hold on.
当黎明开始破晓时，你只能看到悬崖和岩石。船被抬起来又沉下去。开始把同伴冲下海。我差点被冲下去两三次，但我抓住了那根救生索，死死不放。
At about 7:30 in the morning, my father called, and in a somewhat frantic voice said, get down here as quickly as you can. Get ahold of the driver of that pickup truck. Load up all the ropes and lines that you could find in the area and get down to Chambers Cove.
大约早上7点半，我父亲打来电话，用一种相当狂乱的声音说，尽快赶到这里。抓住那辆皮卡车的司机。把你能找到的所有绳子和线装上，然后赶到钱伯斯湾。
The ship had begun to take on so much water, we knew it was going to sink. They had said that no man could live in the water more than five minutes because of the cold.
船开始进水太多，我们知道它要沉了。他们说因为寒冷，没有人能在水里活超过五分钟。
As we came up over the hill and looked down, 300 feet or so below, right in the middle of a horseshoe cove, this destroyer, this Truxtun, partly submerged, but the full length of the rail was still above water. All these people hanging on, if you like, to dear life on the rail. Some were just swept up on those jagged cliffs and then tumble down. It was a pretty dreadful sight.
当我们翻过山头向下望去，在约300英尺下，就在马蹄湾的中间，这艘驱逐舰，这艘特鲁克斯顿号，部分沉没，但栏杆的全长还在水面上。如果你愿意的话，所有这些人都在栏杆上紧紧抓住生命。有些人被冲上那些锯齿状的悬崖，然后翻滚下来。那景象相当可怕。
About this time, she began to break, and all the oil had come out. Oil was coming out, and everybody looked like little rats in the water covered with that crude oil.
就在这时，船开始断裂，所有的油都漏了出来。油漏了出来，每个人看起来都像水里覆盖着原油的小老鼠。
I, along with others, went down hand over hand on a rope.
我和其他人一起，顺着绳子爬了下去。
I told the other blacks that were standing there with me-- I said, at least we're going to die if we're still on board ship. Let's go for it. He said, well, this is Iceland. You don't know what they're going to do. Said, remember, we just left Iceland, and no blacks are allowed. Says, just like being in Georgia or Mississippi.
我告诉和我站在一起的其他黑人——我说，如果我还在船上，至少我们会死。我们去拼一把吧。他说，好吧，这是冰岛。你不知道他们会怎么做。他说，记住，我们刚离开冰岛，不允许任何黑人进入。说，就像在佐治亚州或密西西比州一样。
You mean that you're-- I'm sorry, I'm just trying to absorb this. You're in a life and death situation, getting practically washed off the deck of a destroyer which is breaking up. And there's four or five black guys having a discussion about whether they should actually swim for it or not because they might not be allowed in the land.
你的意思是，你——对不起，我只是试图理解这一点。你处于生死关头，几乎被一艘正在断裂的驱逐舰甲板冲走。还有四五个黑人正在讨论他们是否真的应该游过去，因为他们可能不被允许进入这片土地。
Right. They wanted to stay on board ship rather than take a chance of landing in Iceland. I said, well, we're going to die if we stay on board this ship. I said, at least we can die fighting. I said, let's go. When I jumped in there, it was like I felt just one quick pain that went over my entire body, and it was all over. I didn't feel any pain after that. I just felt sleepy.
没错。他们想待在船上，而不是冒险降落在冰岛。我说，好吧，如果我们待在这艘船上，我们就会死。我说，至少我们可以死在战斗中。我说，走吧。当我跳进去的时候，我感觉全身有一阵剧痛，然后一切都结束了。之后我没有感觉到任何疼痛。我只是觉得昏昏欲睡。
And when we got ashore, I said, well, I made it here. I may as well die. So I just laid down there on the beach, and I closed my eyes to die. This is the end.
当我们上岸时，我说，好吧，我到了这里。我可能会死。所以我只是躺在海滩上，闭上眼睛等死。这就是终点。
And this fellow came, and he said, get him up. Don't let him lie there. He said, pick him up. He will surely die if he lays there. Walk him around. So he pulled me up. And he had on a cap and a coat. I knew he wasn't Navy. And he began to walk me around. And from there, it brought life to me. I said, man, here's a white person who wants me to live. If I had been in Georgia, they would have said, kick him out of the way. Let's help these white people. Then I think I passed out.
然后这个家伙来了，他说，让他起来。别让他躺在那儿。他说，扶他起来。如果他躺在那儿，他一定会死的。带着他四处走走。所以他把我拉了起来。他戴着帽子，穿着外套。我知道他不是海军。他开始带着我四处走动。从那时起，生命回到了我身上。我说，伙计，这里有一个白人想让我活下去。如果我是在佐治亚州，他们会说，把他踢到一边去。让我们去帮助这些白人吧。然后我想我昏过去了。
They took them to where there was a temporary first aid station erected. And of course, the call came to the women of the place to go out to clean them. And that's where the story came in of Lanier now. That little funny story. See, he was there among all the other survivors. The ladies were cleaning them up and scrubbing them up because they were covered with tar, with this oil stuff, this crude oil. They were so filthy, every part of them had to be washed. So when he opened his eyes--
他们把他们带到了一个设立了临时急救站的地方。当然，呼吁当地妇女去清理他们。这就是拉尼尔故事的由来。那个有趣的小故事。你看，他在所有其他幸存者中。女士们正在清理他们，擦洗他们，因为他们身上覆盖着焦油，那种原油。他们太脏了，每个部分都必须清洗。所以当他睁开眼睛——
I could see these white ladies all around. There I was, stark naked, on this table. And I heard one of the ladies say, this is the curliest hair I've ever seen. I said, oh boy, this is the end of me. I said, hell, they're going to say, get him out of here, he's black. And then she said--
我可以看到这些白人妇女在周围。我就这样，赤身裸体地躺在桌子上。我听到其中一位女士说，这是我见过最卷的头发。我说，哦，孩子，这是我的终点。我说，该死，她们会说，让他滚出这里，他是黑人。然后她说——
"This poor fellow. The tar went right into his pores. I'm scrubbing and scrubbing, and I can't get him clean."
“这个可怜的家伙。焦油直接渗进了他的毛孔。我在使劲擦，使劲擦，却无法把他洗干净。”
And I spoke up. She said, I can't get it out. I said, well, you can't get it off. It's the color of the skin.
我说话了。她说，我洗不掉它。我说，好吧，你洗不掉它。那是皮肤的颜色。
And she said, oh, I'll get it off all right. And so she continued to scrub. Violet [? Pike, ?] she's dead now. She had never seen a black man before. So she didn't differentiate. She's out there, thought he was a white man with the black into his pores so bad as she couldn't get it out.
她说，哦，我一定会洗掉它的。于是她继续擦。维奥莱特（派克），她现在已经去世了。她以前从没见过黑人。所以她没有区别对待。她在那里，以为他是一个白人，焦油渗进毛孔太深，她洗不掉。
And I was thinking, oh, boy. They're going to lynch me. Here I am. If I had been in Georgia, they would have ran those white women out of town and maybe lynched me for letting them bathe me.
我在想，哦，伙计。她们会私刑处死我。我在这里。如果是在佐治亚州，她们会把那些白人妇女赶出城，也许还会因为我让她们给我洗澡而私刑处死我。
And of course, when the men were taking them out to the different homes, she said, bring him to my home. So that evening, then, she prepared supper. And he was amazed that he ate with the family. And he drank out of china cups, the same as the family.
当然，当男人们把他们带到不同的家庭时，她说，把他带到我家。那天晚上，她准备了晚餐。他很惊讶自己竟然和家人一起吃晚饭。他用中国茶杯喝水，和家里人一样。
And they put me in the bed. And this lady, she would come in and say, are you warm? Are you all right? And she did this the remainder of the night. I didn't go to sleep anymore because I was still afraid. I didn't know where I was or what was going to happen to me. But then I kept asking myself, did I die, and I went to heaven? What's going on?
他们把我放进床上。这位女士会走进来问，你暖和吗？你还好吗？她整晚都这样。我再也没有睡觉，因为我还是很害怕。我不知道我在哪里，也不知道会发生什么。但我一直问自己，我死了吗？我上天堂了吗？到底发生了什么？
Now look at these pictures, huh? After all these years. Now I'll show you Lanier at that time. There he is. 18 years old, see?
现在看看这些照片，嗯？过了这么多年。现在我给你看那时的拉尼尔。他在那里。18岁，看？
The next morning, they gave me a coat and a cap. And I put these things on, and I wanted to get outside to see what was going on. And I went outside, and Ena was out there taking pictures.
第二天早上，他们给了我一件外套和一顶帽子。我穿上了这些东西，我想去外面看看发生了什么。我走到外面，埃娜在外面拍照。
And I seen him, and I said, come on over and get in the picture.
我看到了他，我说，过来一起拍张照片。
Well, I stood aside. You know, a black is-- the only way he'll take a picture with a white is because how many logs he could lift for the the sawmill, or how many pounds of cotton he could pick in a day, or something like that. He was the white man's prize negro or something like that. And she said, get in, get in, get your picture taken.
好吧，我站在一边。你知道，黑人——他会和白人合影的唯一方式是因为他能为锯木厂举起多少根木头，或者他一天能摘多少磅棉花之类的。他是白人的奖品黑人什么的。她说，进来，进来，拍张照片。
That's him, right there. These are the ones I took with the Brownie.
那就是他，就在那里。这些是我用布朗尼相机拍的。
Four white faces and one black one. This story I'd heard as a joke about the Newfoundlanders who'd tried to scrub the black off a black man. This is like a picture of the joke. But it turns out, the real story doesn't stop here.
四张白人脸，一张黑人脸。我把这个故事当作纽芬兰人试图把一个黑人身上的黑色擦掉的笑话。这就像是那个笑话的照片。但事实证明，真正的故事并没有在这里结束。
Well, it hasn't been a day passed since that happened, it hasn't been a day passed I didn't think about Saint Lawrence. They changed my entire philosophy of life.
从那以后，没有一天我不想到圣劳伦斯。他们改变了我的人生哲学。
So they gave me leave. I think I got 15 days leave. And I went to see my aunt who lived in Chattanooga. And we would catch the bus from there to go into town. And the blacks had to sit behind the whites. And what the whites would do-- if it was only three whites on the bus, maybe two of them would go to the seat just before the last seat, which means that on the way in, if the bus filled up, the whites would have plenty of seats, and the blacks would only have that one seat.
所以他们给了我假。我想我得到了15天的假。我去看了住在那塔努加的姑妈。我们会从那里乘公共汽车进城。黑人必须坐在白人后面。白人会做什么——如果车上只有三个白人，也许其中两个人会坐在倒数第二排座位，这意味着如果车子坐满了，白人会有充足的座位，而黑人只能坐在那一个座位上。
So when we got on, my aunt and I, the back seat was filled, and here was this white guy. So we sat in the seat in front of him. He reached and grabbed me by the neck and pushed me up. And he said, nigger, don't you sit in front of me. And I was going to fight him. I felt like fighting him then because of the treatment that I'd got in Saint Lawrence and what the people have treated me like a human being. I said, well, hell, I'm a human. I'm no longer a slave and the lowest and the least, the last. I said, I'm going to do it. I said, If I can give my life and fight this war the same as everybody else and can't even ride a bus when I pay the same fare as everybody else, but I can't be seated as everyone else--
所以当我们上车时，我和我姑妈，后排座位坐满了，这里坐着这个白人。他伸手抓着我的脖子把我推了起来。他说，黑鬼，别坐在我前面。我正准备和他打架。当时我想和他打架，因为我在圣劳伦斯得到的待遇，以及人们把我当作人类对待。我说，好吧，见鬼，我是个人。我不再是一个奴隶，是最底层、最卑微的人。我说，我要这样做。我说，如果我可以和大家一样献出生命参加这场战争，却连公共汽车都不能坐，即使我支付和大家一样的车费，却不能像大家一样就座——
My aunt said, just be quiet, just be quiet, we'll be in in a few minutes. So I thought about that.
我姑妈说，安静点，安静点，我们几分钟就到了。所以我思考了一下。
Two years after the shipwreck.
沉船两年后。
They sent me to Jacksonville, Florida. And when I got to Jacksonville, I was hungry. And when I got off and walked into the station, I saw all these prisoners, Italian and German prisoners. And they had Army MPs, Americans, guiding them. They had them inside the dining room, eating. And I knew that the blacks could go to a window or something, somewhere, but I knew they wouldn't be allowed to go into that dining room. And I thought about the people of Saint Lawrence, how they had fed me, gave me clothing, and put me in their bed. And I looked at the prisoners. And here I am in American uniform.
他们把我送到佛罗里达州杰克逊维尔。当我到达杰克逊维尔时，我很饿。当我下车走进车站时，我看到了所有这些囚犯，意大利和德国囚犯。他们有美国军队的宪兵引导。他们让他们在餐厅里吃东西。我知道黑人可以去窗口或其他地方，但我知道他们不被允许进入那个餐厅。我想到了圣劳伦斯的人们，他们如何喂我，给我衣服，并让我躺在他们的床上。我看着这些囚犯。而我穿着美国军装。
So I went in to ask, where does a colored-- is what they called us then-- where can call the colored negroes get something to eat? I'm trying to make it to the naval air station. So I went to go in, and this one cop grabbed me by the collar and slung me on the ground. And when he slung me on the ground, he put his foot right on my neck and actually pulled his gun out and pulled the hammer back. I could hear it click. I thought he was going to shoot me.
所以我进去问，有色人种——那是当时叫我们的方式——哪里可以吃东西？我正试图去海军航空站。当我正要进去时，这个警察抓着我的衣领把我甩在地上。当我被甩在地上时，他把脚踩在我的脖子上，实际上掏出了枪，拉开了撞针。我能听到它咔嗒一声。我以为他要杀我。
He say, you black son of a bitch, I'll blow your black brains out. He said, you know better than to come in here where these white people are. So the white people were the German prisoners and the Italian prisoners, and here I am in an American uniform. And I thought about the people of Saint Lawrence.
他说，你这个黑人杂种，我会打爆你的黑人脑袋。他说，你不知道最好别来这儿，这是白人待的地方。所以白人是指德国囚犯和意大利囚犯，而我穿着美国军装。我想到了圣劳伦斯的人们。
16 years after the shipwreck.
沉船16年后。
I was tired of shining shoes. I was tired of washing dishes and pots and pans. I was tired of it. I had 17 years in the navy as a mess attendant. And I was looking, when I get out, I wanted to learn a trade. And I wrote the first black congressman, and I wrote the Bureau of Naval Personnel a letter, and told them I thought I was qualified to be something other than a mess attendant. And when I got that letter back saying, report to Fleet Sonar School, I really gave the credit to Saint Lawrence. Because had it not been for Saint Lawrence, I wouldn't have been writing the powers that be because I had been brainwashed that I was so inferior to the white man, to don't look forward to ever being anything.
我厌倦了擦鞋。我厌倦了洗碗、锅碗瓢盆。我厌倦了。我在海军当了17年的勤务兵。我一直在寻找，等我出去时，我想学一门手艺。我写信给第一位黑人国会议员，也写信给海军人事局，告诉他们我认为自己有资格做勤务兵以外的事情。当我收到那封信说去舰队声纳学校报到时，我真的把功劳归于圣劳伦斯。因为如果不是因为圣劳伦斯，我就不会写信给那些掌权者，因为我已经被洗脑，认为自己比白人卑微得多，不要指望成为任何人物。
And I got orders, report to Fleet Sonar School. They called me down. Counselor wants to see you. And I went in to see a counselor. Phillips, he said, we've got good news.
我接到了命令，去舰队声纳学校报到。他们叫我下去。顾问想见你。我进去见了一个顾问。菲利普斯，他说，我们有个好消息。
Oh, I said, I'm going to start class.
哦，我说，我要开始上课了。
He said, no. We've contacted Washington, and they'll go along with it and make you chief steward mess attendant. He said, because we don't think you can make it through sonar school. I said, well, sir, you can take the first class if you want, I said, but just don't throw me out.
他说，不。我们联系了华盛顿，他们同意了，让你担任首席管家勤务兵。他说，因为我们不认为你能完成声纳学校的学习。我说，好吧，先生，如果你想，你可以拿第一名，我说，但别把我赶出去就行。
He said, well, you know you're going to flunk out, don't you? I said, no, I don't know that. I said, give me a chance. If I flunk out, so be it. He said, all right, you start the next class. So I started the next class, and I went through sonar school.
他说，嗯，你知道你会不及格的，对吧？我说，不，我不知道。我说，给我个机会。如果我不及格，那就这样吧。他说，好吧，你开始上下一课。于是我开始了下一课，我完成了声纳学校。
There's the board, right there. Look.
董事会就在那里。看。
By now, you've probably forgotten how we started this story, driving around Saint Lawrence, 59 years after the shipwreck, with the town historian, Ena Edwards, looking for the brand-new school playground.
现在，你可能已经忘了我们是怎么开始这个故事的，在沉船59年后，带着小镇历史学家埃娜·爱德华兹开车四处寻找全新的学校操场。
See, there's the playground. Established by the students of Marion Elementary School in 1999. You can go out and walk into it. You can go in.
看，那就是操场。由马里昂小学学生于1999年建立。你可以出去走进去。你可以进去。
I'm not a rich man. But every contribution I can make, I make it to the people of Saint Lawrence. I realize since the mine closed, the economy is way down.
我不是个有钱人。但我能做的每一次捐款，我都捐给圣劳伦斯的人们。我意识到自从矿山关闭后，经济非常低迷。
He has shown gratitude. No doubt about it. And they were trying to get a new playground for the elementary school. And I said, well, I have a nice check to present from Lanier.
他表现出了感激之情。毫无疑问。他们正在试图为小学争取一个新操场。我说，好吧，我有一张很好的支票要从拉尼尔那里赠送。
I've said, do whatever the society wants to do with this. I said, But I would like for you to do something for your museum, and let the world know what you did for the entire crew of the Truxtun. And here's this black man, let them know what you did for him too, and how you changed him.
我说过，做社团想做的任何事。我说，但我希望你为你的博物馆做点什么，让世界知道你为特鲁克斯顿号的全体船员做了什么。这里有一个黑人，让他们知道你为他做了什么，以及你是如何改变他的。
There, look. "Lanier Phillips, USS Truxtun survivor. And then on the other side is the USS Truxtun, lost February 18, 1942." And the Marion Elementary School logo is in the center. And the name of the playground is Lanier Phillips playground.
看。 “拉尼尔·菲利普斯，特鲁克斯顿号幸存者。另一边是USS特鲁克斯顿号，沉没于1942年2月18日。”中间是马里昂小学的标志。操场的名字叫拉尼尔·菲利普斯操场。
I seek no recognition. I just want the people of Saint Lawrence to know how much I appreciate them. And I want them to know what they did for me.
我不寻求认可。我只是想让圣劳伦斯的人们知道我有多感谢他们。我想让他们知道他们为我做了什么。
But do you think they're a different kind of people from the people in Georgia?
但你认为他们和佐治亚州的人是不同类型的人吗？
Well, they're the same kind of people. But the reason they are different is because their parents and grandparents or what didn't teach them the hatred and the bigotry that the southern United States taught their kids. We are creatures of what we've been taught, and the people of Saint Lawrence taught me that I was a human being. They put into my mind-- it's etched in there. It's solid, like liquid steel, hot steel became cold and solid. It's into me and will never leave me.
嗯，他们是同一种人。但他们不同的原因是他们的父母和祖父母没有教他们美国南部教给孩子的那种仇恨和偏见。我们是被教导出的产物，圣劳伦斯的人教会了我我是一个人。他们铭刻在我的脑海里——它蚀刻在那里。它是坚固的，就像液态钢，热钢变冷后变得坚固。它在我心里，永远不会离开我。
That story by Chris Brookes, who makes radio stories in Newfoundland, Canada. Lanier Phillips is now 83 and living at the Armed Forces Retirement Home in Washington DC.
那个故事由克里斯·布鲁克斯创作，他在加拿大纽芬兰制作广播故事。拉尼尔·菲利普斯现在83岁，住在华盛顿特区的武装部队退休之家。
You know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。本《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this message for the radio audience:
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他给无线电听众带来了这个信息：
Look at me. Here I am with an infidel.
看着我。这里我有一个异教徒。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。